Malik was just one week shy of his 16th
birthday when a stranger shot him in the
neck on a public bus following a teenage
spat his mother Sharon SAT by his
bedside in hospital for four days and
nights then three days before his
birthday Malik's brain failed and the
machines were turned off forever Sharon
remembers the last time she spoke to her
son it was a good moment he was meeting
me at my daughter school and he came and
you know gave me a big hug told me he
loved me and you know then went on his
way and I went and going to work and I
just never knew that wasn't be my last
hug from him and kiss from him but
that's how he always greets me or that's
how he always leaves me before big hug
and kiss and tells me he loves me so
that was the last time that I greeted
him there is no morning when Sharon does
not wake up without tears in her eyes
what does she feel when she thinks about
her son's murderer and can a jail
sentence ever bring justice it's hard to
put years on my son's life cuz my son
would never come back and um but that's
the only thing that they can do is give
him years so it's just hard
at the end of every year Lisa de littie
writes on t-shirts the names dates of
birth and death of each person who has
been shot dead during the last 12 months
it's a transportable political Memorial
which delete he plans to install outside
churches in Greater Washington next year
there'll be a shirt for Moloch to each
t-shirt represents a human being and I
have a problem with the Congress that
doesn't remember that they're human
beings being killed by these guns that
there are mothers and fathers and
sisters and brothers who are not with us
anymore because someone had easy access
to a gun and that we need to do
something about this seems to be little
in this bitterly contested election year
that could offer some hope to parents
like Sharon that they won't have to live
in fear of losing another child to gun
violence